we're approaching another season and you
all know what time it is
it's time for another one of my
pre-season videos get ready because
we're gonna have a pretty wild season
one that's nowhere near lacking in both
new shows of different genres
and sequels to popular titles i don't
want you to have to look far
especially since we're still in the
middle of just as amazing season but you
can't help but be excited for what's to
come right so without further ado
let me present my top 10 picks for the
most anticipated titles this summer 2021
but
before we do anything else i'd like to
encourage you to hit that like and
subscribe button are you ready to see
what the anime industry has for you
let's dive in and find out we start off
with spirit chronicles
[Applause]
what happens after death if you're an
anime you get reincarnated into another
world of course but have you considered
what happens to your memories
take it further and think of what
happens when it's only your memories to
get reincarnated
and those memories of the past are
intersecting with those of another
person in the other world now that's a
mouthful now isn't it but that's the
basic premise of the upcoming haram
isakai spirit chronicles
that i feel is a rather novel premise in
the sea of issachai and i feel it just
highlights how the genre has maintained
traction for so long there are many ways
to go about a reincarnation story
and with even the slightest twist and
change in circumstances you can come up
with a story that feels fresh i've yet
to read the source material and i'm
pretty sure that some parts of the
series do rehash some common standards
and tropes of the harem isakai genre but
it still comes off as unique in its own
execution
this is one of the shows that i'll be
looking forward to i'm so excited to
hear kirito's japanese
voice actor in yet another fantasy harem
[Music]
ninth on the list is the honor student
at magic high school
now this i didn't expect when irregular
at magic high school
unexpectedly got its new season a year
ago i expected it to be a short one and
a done deal with just a core to help
promote the sequel novels
turns out that just like the do aru
series we have here an extended revival
with the most notable spin-off on a
student getting green lit for an anime
this time we move away from godzilla and
we see the story through miyuki's
perspective
it surely provides a different
experience as compared to irregular and
magic high school and we get to see more
of the side characters and their lovable
interactions for those who are fans of
miyuki's two best friends you'll also
get to see them a lot here i do have to
note the drastic art style change
it kind of caught me off guard but i
think it's just fitting considering the
more easy going nature of the series
compared to the mainline one the ride
isn't over for fans of the franchise and
this
is looking to be a fun light-hearted
take on the same universe
next in line is how a realist hero
rebuilt the kingdom
this is a series that i've been hearing
about for quite a while so i'm not
exactly shocked that this one got an
anime it's one of the more talked about
isakai series that has to deal with the
titular kingdom building our protagonist
of this town is a student who finds
himself in yet another world however
instead of being the great hero that
people expected him to be gazuya soma
decides to go the more practical route
instead of slaying demon lords and the
like he seeks to rebuild the struggling
economy of the kingdom he finds himself
in being abruptly planted to the throne
is probably not the easiest position to
navigate but our hero looks to put his
knowledge of realism and
machiavellianism
in order to take the country to glorious
new heights how a realist hero rebuilt
the kingdom has a title that's quite
self-explanatory in lieu of the usual
fighting and adventuring we have a hero
who seeks to become a hero through
political reform it's a series that
prides itself on the political aspects
the world building and sprinkling of
harryman comedy aspects we'll see how
that translates onto the screen this
summer
come on moving on we have
peach boy riverside
tell me if you've heard of this premise
before bright cheerful princess wants to
go on an adventure before finding her
life turned upside down by demons
however they were dispatched by a lone
traveler a mysterious enigma who
possesses an equivalent of the artifact
of power with this major life-changing
event
princess decides to set off on an
adventure of her own the premise for
peach boy riverside may seem plain but i
think that what gives this show a unique
dynamic
is how the characters act the teaser art
alone should be a tip everyone in this
show is rather acts
crazy to put it lightly yanderes are us
as they say it certainly seems to be one
of the crazier and more over-the-top
shows that you can indulge yourself in
this season if the premise interests you
you don't have to wait too long
it's also a series from the creator of
dragon maid which we'll also be seeing
this season so if you're a fan of the
creator's works
putting this show on your to-watch list
should be an easy decision
there i spoiled an entry already and i'd
like you to guess which place that title
would be
coming up is my next life as a
villainess season two
fans didn't have to wait too long for
the sequel to my next life as a
villainess
it's only been a year but we'll finally
get the continuation to katarina's
hilarious quest to avoid all bad ends it
was a show that helped propel the
villainess genre into the mainstream
and i feel there's no better candidate
to do so hamefura as the show is
commonly called has great character
growth and story progression the comedy
also works and i say that it never goes
stale or bland even if you were someone
who's grown jaded with anime style
comedy i felt that my life as a
villainess was quite entertaining on its
own the dynamics between characters were
entertaining and i like how it had a
harem of developed characters that
featured both sexes i truly enjoyed what
it brings to the table and it was a
breath of fresh air when put beside a
lot of the isakai titles that we've seen
in recent years this one deserved its
second season
and i'm eagerly awaiting it
[Music]
we have a non-sequel coming up now the
detective is already dead
seems to be your by the book anime
protagonist from getting caught up in
crime scenes to having disaster follow
him everywhere it just seems that he'd
eventually find himself
a detective assistant to a mysterious
girl named siesta the two would have
adventures until
siesta's untimely death having resigned
himself to an ordinary life
gimizuka finds the wheels of his life
turning once more
this time in the form of another girl
who looks a bit too much like siesta for
comfort
i guess it's about time for another
detective anime and having read some of
the source material
i think is a pretty interesting take on
the genre it's quite genre savvy and has
a lot of references to the detective
fiction genre and the character banter
just makes it so fun
to read i'm curious to see how well the
light novel will be adapted but i sure
am keeping my hopes up for this one
so we now return to sequels with the
second part of reincarnated as a slime
season 2.
hilarious slice of life version however
come summer it's time to check back in
with the main plot that's left us
hanging for quite a while the last time
we saw rimaru and friends our
protagonists had completed his evolution
into a demon lord while at it he also
added a new member to the squad a new
subordinate called diablo with this new
character coming into play as the newest
addition to the team you gotta wonder
how that shakes things up if there's one
thing that i would use to describe
slime's adaptation
it's consistency you can tell that 8bit
has been consistently giving their all
in helping the hit novel series
make the leap into the anime format and
it's been a joy at seeing a lot of the
novel's iconic scenes and epic fight
animated as well as they have been for
some sly may be yet another itakai
featuring a crazily overpowered
protagonist but for me i think that this
is one of the more intriguing ones and
an example of the sub-genre done right
slime fans the wait is no more this
season rimaru will make waves around the
community once more
[Music]
for the first entry in our top three we
have the case study of vanitas
[Music]
the book of vanitas has received its
fair share of fanfare as a manga that
mixes a bit of
historical settings with supernatural
vampire action given that it's by the
same creator of pandora hearts we can
really see some similar vibes shared
between the two works
it follows vanitas a legendary vampire
so powerful
and hated by his own kind alone he
created the book of vanitas a grimoire
that would one day allow him to exact
revenge against the world's vampires
the legendary grimoires attracted
widespread interest and our protagonist
noe
is one of those looking to find the
cursed treasure however a sudden vampire
attack on route to paris allows him to
encounter the famed vanitas himself
however in contrast to his reputation
vanitas is actually just an ordinary
human who specializes in vampires
perhaps there's more to this mysterious
man and the grim what he possesses
one that seems suspiciously like the
book of vanitas of legend
weaving together an air of mystery and
gripping narrative this should be one of
the hits this season
the second most anticipated summer anime
is the second season of miss kobayashi's
dragon maid
it seems not so long ago when i was
finding myself bopping to the catchy
opening tune of miss kobayashi's dragon
maid laughing at the show's comedy and
generally having fun with this offering
from joe any
oh and the social media reception to the
characters is something we can laugh
back to dragon maid in his first season
may seem like a silly comedy at first
glance but it also unironically gave us
some insights to what life in japan
could be like under the guise of the
crazy premise of dragons and maid as
well as the over-the-top comedy of
course
it's a show that knows what it is and
doesn't compromise anything in order to
pretend to be something it's not as such
you won't be seeing big dramatic twists
or some forced tearjerkers instead the
show focused on the like comedic aspects
and did an
excellent job at it it's all fun
light-hearted and relaxing for a show
like this it's the perfect combination
to help you unwind after a stressful day
at work
much like the main character i fully
expect that pace to stay this season and
it's a good thing with some new
characters coming
i'm really excited to see what they
bring to the table i'm very looking
forward to seeing thoru and the gang
again
i know some fans from 2017 are going to
be feeling the same way
finishing off our list is the much
awaited return of mushoku tensei
i made it seem like it's been so long
for what was just a one season break but
i'm sure that the way it's been killing
mushoku tensei fans already we last left
the story with rudy's group in the demon
continent
having formed an unofficial party of
three with aerys and an unexpected ally
with roxy also arriving to the scene
what adventures away our protagonist in
the next phase of the story you know i
really gave mushoku tensei too little
credit in my preseason videos i know of
its reputation and i know of its
strengths however the actual adaptation
is what blew me away
you don't see this amount of dedication
every day with how the show's been
carefully adapted and all the top-notch
quality and production you can really
tell that this is such a big deal sure
mushoku tensei is still the ever
controversial show that it is but i
think that those who enjoy issachai with
slow
methodical builds and development this
series is very much worth a try you also
likely won't get a cop out reading the
novel's ending because
multiple sources have stated that
mushoku tensei is intended to be a long
runner much in the vein of stuff like
sword art online which means you could
be seeing mushoku tensei
all the way to the next decade
so which anime are you most excited for
write down in the comments section down
below if you enjoyed the video
make sure to give it a like a thumbs up
and a share for those who prefer to
directly contribute to the channel
memberships are available and they'll
give you access to some member locked
videos i'm currently looking to find new
and innovative ways to spice up
membership rewards so why not being the
first in line when something happens my
patreon is also open and you're free to
contribute to the cause which will allow
me to make even better videos when the
time is right that's it for now hope you
had a good time watching the video and
picking up shows that interest you for
the season i'll be signing off and i
hope you have a good day
[Music]
[Applause]